same thing as Larry PA and Serj bin they
brought in Eric Schmidt because he was
going to be the leader that was going to
help grow Google Now they were amazing
product people incredibly good
technologist but he knew how to build
and operate the actual company and so
was it a bad move for them to do that
absolutely not obviously worked out for
them and so having that level of self
awareness and humility to be able to
quote hand over the Reigns to an
operator can sometimes be the most
valuable thing that you do the business
especially from an Enterprise Value
perspective if you want to own something
that can ultimately work without you in
the future